-Yes! That is what
I'm talking about.
Looking good, bud.
Looking good.
-We can't forget.
We can't forget.
Everybody's to get out there
and do their thing.
-You actually been talking a lot
about the importance of voting
and encouraging people to vote.
And, you know, I follow you
on all the socials.
You found a different way
to bring attention to this
by posting this photo.
Come on. Come on.
-Yeah. Listen.
-Come on.
-I got to tell you, I don't know
what's going on there.
I had good lighting.
-Oh, please.
-I had -- Listen, Jimmy.
I had just moisturized.
The cocoa butter
was in full effect.
You know what I'm saying?
-There's a couple abs in there.
I will never see --
I think I almost have one ab.
I found it the other way.
It was, like, floating around --
It's that or a hernia.
But it's something, and I go,
"Ooh, this is something."
I could never post
something like that,
but you got to get people out
and get people talking.
-You got to do
what you got to do, man.
Listen. If showing a little bit
of flesh means that people
will be incentivized
to go ahead and register,
it's an important vote.
I'll press a little flesh.
Why not?
-You've always been
in good shape.
And I was seeing the things
you've been doing in quarantine.
Have you taught yourself
anything or any hobbies?
-Okay. So, check it out.
I did start taking piano lessons
during the quarantine.
-You did?
-Now, listen, I cant --
I can't get out there
with you and The Roots
or anything like that,
but I can play a few little
jingles around the house.
And it's relaxing.
-Wow.
-It relaxes me.
-That's amazing.
-I have an instructor,
who's a really cool guy.
He's about ten years
younger than me.
And I have a ping-pong table
in my garage.
Now, I don't get a chance to
play ping-pong with anybody,
but he saw the table
and he's like, "Do you play?"
And I was like, "You know.
I do a little something.
Like, I'm all right."
He's like, "Do you maybe --
You want to play with me?
And I'm like, "Yeah, bud.
Yeah, I'll play with you."
So we were like two kids.
After like 30 minutes
on the piano,
he's like, "Okay, so...
you want to go play now?"
And I was like, "Yeah."
And my wife is like,
"What are you guys doing?"
I was like, "Oh, we're going to
go play a little ping-pong.
We good?"
Every piano lesson, Jimmy,
is 30 minutes on the piano
and about 2 to 2 1/2 hours
on the ping-pong table.
-You have a new friend.
You're like a little kid.
-I have a new --
It's the best thing because
you're socially distanced.
It's one of those things where
you play hard, you're sweating.
Like, you're sweating.
You're not thinking about
anything else.
And I think more than anything,
there is so much
on people's minds
during this pandemic.
It was nice to have something
to turn it off for a second
and just try to hit
this little ball over the net.
-I saw, also, that your youngest
son, I believe, he's 5?
-Amaré. Yeah, he's 5.
-He tried to cut his own hair.
I thought that was pretty funny.
How did that go?
And when did you find out?
-My little Negro,
African-American, Black child,
God bless him, he saw some
scissors just in the house.
And his hair was growing longer,
and he's like,
"I'm gonna help everybody else
in the house out.
Like, I can see that there's
a need that needs to be met."
So he goes,
he picks up the scissors,
and he got himself, like,
right in the middle.
And my wife
took a picture of him.
And God bless him.
It's not like he thought
he was in trouble or anything.
I was like, "Amaré,
did you just cut your hair?"
And he's like, "Yeah.
It needed to be cut, so I did."
And I was like, "All right.
Well, look in the mirror, bro.
Like, how do you feel about it?
Are you enjoying it?"
And he's like,
"Yeah, this is great."
-It's, like, parted
in the middle.
-I love that --
Listen. I have two little boys.
On the TV show,
I have three little girls.
But with the little boy, I just
take out the razor, man.
I take that ish
all the way down,
and then we just
start over again.
-And he was cool with it?
-He was totally cool.
He loved it.
-Sterling, I want to talk about
"This is Us" because --
Man, I'm so psyched
that you guys are back.
I'm happy
you are doing it safely.
But how did it feel to be back?
Is it different? Is it odd?
-It's different,
and it feels like home.
You're away from it,
and you're like,
"I want to get back
to this thing that I love."
-Yep.
-Like, I love it so much.
Not only the stories,
but the people.
You know what I'm saying?
-Yeah.
-So however you can get back
to each other safely,
it feels so good, man.
Like, honest to goodness.
There's a ton of protocols
in place
to make sure
that we can do it safely,
but we're all overjoyed
to be back on the air.
-I read somewhere that
the creator, the writer.
Is it -- Dan Fogelman.
That he wanted this to come out
now, as soon as it can,
because you somehow incorporated
the pandemic
and also Black Lives Matter
movement into the show.
-Yeah.
-That's going to be interesting
to see how you guys do that.
-I think Dan, being sort of the
civic-minded individual,
felt like we had created
something
that would connect
with the populace.
I think the special thing
about our show is that everyone
gets a chance to see a
reflection of themselves in it.
I think
leading up to this election,
I think he felt like
it was important
that people sees themselves.
-Everyone's looking forward
to it.
I'll definitely be watching.
I want to show everyone a clip
from the season premiere.
Here is Sterling K. Brown in the
new season of "This is Us."
Take a look.
-Daphne says if you touch your
face, you automatically get it.
-You might.
-Deja, come on.
-Hey, this thing is serious.
People need to wake the hell up.
-Okay. Yeah. Understood.
But, Mom, if you guys
change your mind
and want to come stay here...
Okay. I know.
-Holy crap.
-Hey, Mom, I'll call you later.
I love you.
Well, the clinical trial
is officially postponed.
After all that.
Thank God Mom and Miguel
went to the cabin
before St. Louis.
She said she's comfortable.
She'll ride it out there.
-Tom Hanks got it.
-Hanks got the corona?
-Hanks got the corona.
-Oh. I gotta call Kate.
-Randall --
-No, it's Tom Hanks, babe.
She got to hear this from me.
♪♪
-People are going to
wake up now.
-Sterling K. Brown, thank you
so much for being here.
You know it means a lot to me
that you come on the show.
-Always.
-"This is Us" returns for
a two-hour season premiere
tomorrow night
at 9:00 p.m. on NBC.